and his team
have never been more in demand
their ambulance used to carry the living
then a third wave of covert 19 hit
myanmar
and now everyone they pick up is dead
hour after hour they collect bodies
people who survived a military takeover
only to be defeated by coronavirus
the line of ambulances at the
crematorium is a sign of the crisis
for hours they wait to deliver the dead
july has been grim more than 50 percent
of the country's
total covert fatalities lost in one
month
february's military coup triggered a
doctor's strike that
fatally wounded the health system the
delta variant
has all but finished it off
the desperate hang yellow flags begging
for help
this man's father needs oxygen
but so too do all their relatives
so again they queue this time for
life-saving air
as loved ones die waiting
no one is safe on the corners teams of
body collectors wait
and at homes as they carry the dead they
mourn for their own
bo's father recently taken by the virus
many now are dying at home the medics
who can save them
hunted and arrested for opposing the
coup
some forced to work in secret at great
risk
one doctor agreed to speak to me
anonymously
his clinic's been raided by the military
three times
in six months the hunter is weaponizing
the coveted situation
for their own benefits so they don't
care about their patient
situation they don't care about the
oxygen crisis they don't care about the
what's happening in on ground situation
they only care about their power
all people can do now is try to survive
the military hasn't replied to our
request for comment
it's been securing more vaccines and
medicine as have the opposition
but covid19 brought the world's most
powerful
nations to their knees without more help
myanmar a state on the brink of collapse
doesn't stand a chance siobhan robbins
sky news in bangkok